hi I'm Steve Weintraub and I run the
website collider and I am thrilled to be
at the collider Studio sponsored by
Saratoga Water a huge thank you to
Saratoga because we cannot be here
without a sponsor Sundance is expensive
[Laughter]
though no BS it's because of the glass
plastic makes things taste like and
glass makes things taste great I agree
it's a really it's why beer is in glass
yeah it's a recycled Blue Glass I'm
going to say it's recycled from Avatar
people yes and you know but anyway so
I'm here to talk about Fairyland which I
thought was fantastic but before we get
into Fairyland you were mentioning Wiki
feet and I wanted to find out uh where
did this come from
I have a great Wiki feed I I you know
your opening shot in the movie is your
bare feet
that's right and that was strategic
because we know you have a big Wiki feed
following yeah yeah
so it's what Finance the film it is
exactly what Finance the film wiki feet
uh I by the way I appreciate you uh and
indulging me with my stupid questions at
the beginning I have a few quick ones
you worked at the very beginning of your
career as like an office PA or something
on the first screen movie if I'm not
mistaken wow yeah I was yeah I I was
like assistant production coordinator on
scream yeah the very original screen oh
I know and so I'm curious when you were
making that did you have any idea that
movie was going to go on to become what
it's become
I had I had no idea but I think that the
people at Dimension
um must have had some idea because they
put Drew Barrymore in it
um at the beginning you know and she was
kind of a hot deal I mean well she still
is but she was a big deal so
um but it was um I thought I was it was
a gig for me I was working freelance in
production I'd you know been out of film
school for a few years and this was a
great job I got to be up in Santa Rosa
and Sonoma County and we would drink
wine on the weekends I made some
wonderful friends on that we just
thought it was a blast we did not know
it was going to turn into the franchise
that it became but I have a feeling that
some people had an idea perhaps I'm
curious for you uh when did you decide
you wanted to take over Sundance this
year with the with two films
I'm honestly I'm so excited to be here
because Coda we didn't actually get to
come to Sundance and so everything was
online and so that then when I found out
that Fairyland and cat person were
trying I was like I really hope that at
least one of them could get in so I
could finally go to Sundance I did not
think it would be both so I'm I'm on
cloud nine I'm very shocked
um would it be okay with everyone if I
spoke about Halt and Catch Fire for the
next 30 minutes
no
huge fan I love the show but um but and
I know that you're a you're a huge fan
this is just me busting your balls for
sure when I talked to Jake Gyllenhaal
all I talk about is zodiac every single
time and um it's just a thing you know
um so I'm gonna stop here I apologize I
have individual questions for you but uh
publicist is gonna you know grab me and
say F you so I'm just gonna let's jump
in I thought your movie's fantastic
thank you uh and it's also just such an
important movie and it's beautifully
told but no one here who is watching the
interview and a lot of people in the
room haven't seen it yet so how have you
been describing the film to friends and
family
well friends and family have been
listening to me describe it for the last
eight years so um they they all know it
very well it's been a long time in the
making
um but I would say to some if like an
elevator pitch type of thing I would say
this is a um
uh a
father-daughter Love Story set during
um
a period in a period in America that was
on the cusp of changing
um in so many ways and we watched we
watched them sort of evolve with the
times it's a parallel Coming of Age
story
um uh this is a story of a daughter or a
young girl raised by a gay father and if
you know anything about that sort of
community back then a lot of those men
that came out of the closet in the 1970s
during the gay Liv movement were going
through sort of a second adolescence and
um because they had sort of suppressed
that initial adolescent so uh the it
just so happens that his daughter is
sort of coming of age as he is coming of
age again so we're watching these two
worlds
um Collide and also
um connect
is very uh I think you've done this
before that's the first time anyone's
asked me that question so thank you
seven floors in an elevator yes we are
now
we're going up the world trade
for the four of you um I'm curious this
is such a beautifully told
um story and I can't imagine what was it
like for each all four of you what was
it like reading the script for the first
time and what made you say oh my God I
have to be a part of this
um when I initially read the script the
first time uh I mean it resonated with
me the fifth first time I read it and
just it resonated with me just as much
the 50th time I read it
um and even like seeing it today it's
still it still resonates Andrew wrote an
incredibly beautiful script and and I
don't I know that he had it for a really
long time but the script spoke for
itself
um it was a really beautiful story you
know about a father-daughter Love Story
um set during the AIDS epidemic and and
um but it more so it's just it's it's it
it's about these two sort of figuring it
out and trying to to do better and be
better and figure out who they are as
people
um it's just a story that you have you
kind of hear about but it's it's never
it's not a movie I've seen or a story
that I've seen in the cinema before um
and so it was original it was a
beautiful story he had written
um the cast was incredible
um it was it was it was a no-brainer I
mean it was a small movie but I think we
all cleared our
schedules to come do this thing we all
really really passionate wanting to do
it and I've I've been attached for six
years I think it's six years Cody was
the very first person attached to the
movie and don't you forget it
um I was I
was so enamored of the script and so
wanted it to happen and
years went by when it wasn't happening
and I kind of just assumed well you know
I'm not going to get to do this and
Andrew and I stayed in touch and I would
kind of hound him every December I think
like what's happening
um and then it all came together like it
seemed like within the space of a week I
found out that scoot was doing it and I
instantly became terrified
um because he's just I've always seen
him as such a phenomenal artist the kind
of actor that you like okay I've really
got to bring my a game and I was at an
Oscars party and when you and I met and
you were like Fairyland and I was like
what about it and you were like I'm I'm
Alicia and I was like what you know
um and
then it was like all happening it all it
all came together within the space of
like two weeks and we were off to San
Francisco and shooting
um and it was such an extraordinary
experience the whole time
that's my experience of it the whole 21
days that we Shot the movie in yeah it
was a whirlwind win but I think that's
what's so exciting about independent
movie making it brings out such like
such a rawness on screen and you know it
is it's 21 days and you've got to film
like you know young Alicia old Alicia
through you know loads of years and it
was tough but everybody just worked so
hard together and it really was a team a
team effort and I uh I loved every
second of it even though it was hard
when we were up against it with time I
just uh yeah I loved it and the story it
was so beautiful I read the Memoir and I
read the script and I fell in love with
it and I did actually audition for
Andrew before the pandemic and then I
didn't hear where to zoom and then we
try to zoom like the first week of the
pandemic didn't we we were both at our
homes you were it wasn't called Zoom
then it was called Skype yeah
yeah and then it I didn't hear anything
and I thought I did I didn't get it and
then uh and then I yeah I got a call
months later and uh yeah I was so
excited to be doing it it's a really
beautiful story
you have a small but important part in
the film can you but you haven't talked
about what Drew to the project so I'm
just curious
um yeah well Andrew reached out um and
we had a great conversation
um and you told me about the Memoir and
I read it and I thought it was beautiful
um I I've always loved San Francisco in
the 70s particularly in the Castro that
you know the Gay Liberation movement I
have ex you know my my mom's side of the
family they lived there in the Castro
during that time
um it it hits home for me like that was
a very nostalgic sort of era
um based on stories I've heard
um and I just thought it was a different
you know there are lots of queer Stories
being told right now and it's really
important and it's something that's sort
of long overdue you know there's more
and more uh
characters coming out there's more and
more stories I feel like you know we're
at a time where queer stories and
visibility are more important than ever
and they're the reason why we have been
able to move the needle in the first
place I think the media TV film music
we're the ones actually helping get
people comfortable with the queer
experience but this movie in particular
was just so interesting because you're
you're kind of colliding the gay Libra
movement with a single father raising a
child and I just I thought it was so
interesting to see those things kind of
mash together in such a beautiful way
um this you mentioned that you had a
tight schedule to make this and I'm
curious when you were looking for
when you're looking at the schedule what
was the day that you had circled like
how the f are we going to pull this off
and also for the actors was there a day
on the schedule that you were a little
bit concerned or nervous about I'm
trying to think of a day that wasn't
that day it's just so so do you
understand that when you have a
seven-year-old they can only work five
hours a day so what we did is we worked
yeah we yeah we would shoot uh Nessa
Doherty who was the wonderful little
girl that plays young Alicia we would
shoot her in the mornings
um and then she would leave at lunch and
then Amelia would come and we would
shoot her scenes now remember scoot has
to go from 70s to 80s at lunchtime so he
would have to switch his hair and makeup
and everything and we'd also have to do
our company moves are minor we shot most
of the movie in two large homes
um two big old houses for our Interiors
so the company moves are easy but we
would shoot uh young Alicia in the
morning older Alicia at night we'd shoot
the morning was on 16 millimeter the
evening the camera Department switched
to digital
um it was like shooting two films and we
always said that uh so when you asked
that question if there was one day that
was crazy I don't the day that we shot
the gay pride parade in the 70s that was
it was well it was a heatwave but also
it was like day two or three of shooting
yeah and there were three company moves
which is a lot for a movie on our
schedule so that might have been a tough
one because we had a couple different
locations and you know it was it was it
was all kind of very diff it was
complicated shoot to do but but you
wouldn't have known it I mean Andrew
handled it so deftly it was such a punk
experience shooting like like I remember
coming in like in the makeup room I'd be
in character and I'd come in and there
would be Amelia getting her hair done
and we'd kind of go off and do something
and then Nessa would be going and the
entire time Andrew was so calm and he'd
kind of come in with his little green
and his Direction was yeah so how you
feeling I was like yeah yeah it's good
he's like okay yeah my yeah all right
then you know like
you never knew that anything
's a problem he was like okay we've got
to get this so let's do it you know it
was just it felt like Indie filmmaking
in the best possible sense a
collaboration with a leader who was
really who knew what he wanted and who
delivered yeah no matter how stressful
it was it never showed ever and I have
to say I I this is my first film
um I've I've been in the entertainment
industry for a long time in other you
know theater and music and stuff but I
was a little apprehensive you know I was
like well I hope that that I know what
I'm doing and I hope that they like me
and that I don't things up and and
I have to say it was such a breeze it
was so comfortable right away Andrew was
like just made me feel like everything
was going to be fine I I walked on to
set and met scoot he gave me a big hug
and he was like I'm so excited I
instantly felt like okay this is gonna
be great I met Amelia it was just like
it felt very relaxed and that the family
had already sort of been formed but I
wasn't I didn't feel like an outsider
when I walked onto set and I thought
that was really wonderful I mean you
know I've I've seen it the other way
it helps giving everyone a five dollar
bill before you stand on set or a
hundred yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly I I I've done a couple films um
and uh Andrew is a light in a bottle
um
he's just so wonderful to work with but
also he's wonderful to like be around
like you you want to go get drinks or a
dinner with them afterwards you kind of
want to he's very very magnetic
um and so
it trickles down from the top obviously
we all know that and like when you have
a leader that keeps their composure and
keeps their Creative Vision going it and
their composure it's it's it's rare and
uh Andrew I did it gracefully
an extraordinary team of producers as
well I mean you have Sophia Coppola and
you have Megan Carlson and you know they
were real leaders on this film and uh
everything just felt like a family
experience and so you knew I know I was
like
Sophia what
sorry I didn't mean to interrupt I'm so
sorry that was that was really it I mean
it was just as a team you don't get this
often and it was such a Love Fest it was
just so easy and gentle and
humorous and light and at the same time
obviously tackling such you know intense
issues
kudos to Andrew well one of the reasons
why I'm so happy this film was made is
there's a lot of obviously younger
people that are not familiar with that
era and it always anytime I think about
the late 70s or early 80s of San
Francisco in the mid 80s I just think
about all the people that were lost AIDS
and who just never had a chance and it's
just a generation of people and this
film shines a light on on that story and
so can you talk a little bit about that
aspect
um
yeah it's a little emotional for me I'm
gonna pass that on to someone else
um I was no I'm sorry no it's okay it's
um it's a tough one
I was not educated on the I mean I knew
a little bit about it but not to the
extent that I know and
the tragedy that came across this
community that was totally sidelined
um after going to a coveted pandemic
that doesn't even
ring close to what the AIDS
it's like one of the saddest things in
the world to know that like what if you
went through the coveted pandemic and
you had nobody
and this community small community had a
lot of Pride had gained a lot of ground
with their movement
only to be
it's just a tragedy it's so sad it's
just so sad
um and that was the one thing that hit
me in doing the research for this of
I didn't know much about the
he's always grew up in Texas I was
sheltered from it
um and Having learned a lot about this I
I didn't understand I I now realize the
tragedy that this community went through
and no one was sticking their hands out
to help
it's it's a shameful time in America in
America's history and
um but one of the reasons why I'm so
happy this film was made is because we
have to talk about it and we can't bury
these things under the rug and that's
one of the reasons why you know one of
the many reasons why I thought you did
such a fantastic job well that's also
why I made the film and I didn't mean it
not answer your question but I probably
like so many of us have a little PTSD
from that era so it's hard for us to go
there so that's why the film is here and
I I will say too like I I missed that
era by 10 years or so and
um but growing up sort of in the the
shadow of it like the aftermath of it
the fear that was around sex and
homosexuality permeated the 90s you know
as I was a kid in the 90s but like you
could feel it anything that you saw on
TV about anything gay was like everyone
was freaked out you know because of what
had happened and um I think
I think looking at today's Community
like the lgbtq community today
especially young people coming up
there's a lot of the history that we
haven't passed on to our community
there's a lot of it that's been lost a
lot of our teachers were taken away from
us a lot of the people that would now be
our elders don't exist anymore and the
the history that the the queer Community
has been through is really important now
more than ever considering what's going
on in the country considering that like
I said earlier we're under sort of
attack again we've got to like we gotta
make sure everyone knows what's what's
happened already and so that we can not
repeat our mistakes and we can build
upon what we can learn from it and and
come out stronger and more unified so I
don't want to do any spoilers in the
movie but you two have some very
emotional scenes in the third act and
I'm just curious we could talk a little
bit about playing those scenes and
making them as authentic as you can
because for me when I was watching I
felt like I was watching real people who
are just flawed but trying to make the
best of it it and I thought you both did
such an amazing job
well luckily for us and by the time
without acting those really really
emotional scenes they were at the very
end of the shoot so by that point I had
become really close with school I'd
become close with Andrew we'd all become
really really close and we developed our
characters
and so when it came to those really
really emotional scenes I was really
really sad I fell in love with with
scoots Steve and we also were coming to
an end of the shoot and it was emotional
and I'd learned so much about that time
and I it it was kind of no acting
required it Andrew did really long takes
which I loved because I felt like I was
living as Alicia and I was in that
moment and it never felt like acting I
never noticed the camera around
especially Greta at the way Greta shot
those scenes as well she kind of just
let us be it wasn't like okay but now
we're gonna go close so now we're gonna
go close now we're gonna do a wide now
we're gonna do this shot it was just me
and school in that moment
um and we didn't do it many many times
which which helped I think and made it
more emotional
um uh for me like working with
um Talent like Amelia
um you just have to listen like it when
you work with really talented people
it's like there's less work for you to
do
um especially in acting and so just to
be present and like just like listen
that that's it even with Nessa the
little girl you you just sort of really
listen to them and like they're rock
stars like they will they will get you
there you know what I mean if you just
stay focused and just listen to them
because they were both I mean that's an
incredible job it's her first movie but
you know Amelia is a a pro and so you
you know
when you work with somebody like that
there's not just it's not work it's play
you I was going to say you have a fun
scene with Nessa
I don't want to I don't want to spoil it
here but I'm curious what it was like
filming a certain scene that is dealing
with adult stuff maybe
what was really great about
um I mean like just just as an aside you
know Indie filmmaking
I got into that that bath and it was
freezing cold do you remember like the
water's warm it'll be great and well
there was no running water in that house
so we had to just fill a bathtub with
water that was I don't know from the
hose that's right yeah so they're like
they'll like jump into the bath it's
going to be great and I was like this is
-10 degrees
um and
you know okay I'll say something about
that I remember early on Scoot and I
kind of looking at each other at the
start of the film
because Andrew was so gentle that he
would kind of you know the camera would
be off in the distance or something we'd
kind of be doing our thing and he he
knew what he wanted and we were like
we've got all these ideas and we've got
all this and he was just kind of like oh
no I want you to be in the distance and
I want and it was the same with the bath
scene he put the camera in a certain
place and I was thinking you know
there's going to be coverage it's going
to be a close-up I was going to make all
these choices and
and he said no no just sit in the
bathroom we're just going to do it and I
it feels like it was the first take
um
well we straight fell in we didn't have
many takes on this movie because we
didn't have time so oh the ashtray did
fall in that was the first take yeah
you're right so it was it was the shock
of you know you're you're kind of
dealing with that situation as it's
unraveling and everything just felt so
authentic
um and Nessa is such a special little
soul you know she's she's so vibrant and
curious and fun and so again it's like
scoot said you just kind of need to
lock in and go
um so Andrew I'm one of the things that
I commend you on and you touched on a
little bit earlier in the interview is I
like the way the aesthetic of the film
and how you use 16 millimeter for the
you know the 70s and you know and then
you you shot a completely different once
it became uh you know in the 80s um can
you talk about the choices you made why
you wanted to do it like that
um it was a very very conscious decision
and this was something that um when
Greta who RDP is just incredible we'll
all continue I mean she was she's
amazing she was one of the most agile
um
intelligent I mean her aesthetic is
incredible but we we decided we wanted
to make sure that this film
uh sort of matured as our characters
matured if that makes sense so in the
beginning of it we shoot a lot of it on
on the first half everything with this
is on 16 millimeter and
um and that and that camera work is it's
just a little bit more fluid and more
verite and
um and we shoot up a lot we should we're
looking up at Steve for most of that
part um most of Nessa scenes and then
when we get to those teenage scenes
since the 1980s and we introduce Amelia
we transitioned to digital and we're
we're looking a little bit more eye line
with Steve at this point our shots are
still a little messy and playful but it
isn't until we get to the third act
where now we're looking down at Steve
and the shots are a lot more stable
they're more sort of conservative
compositions and and that was just a
really important
really important to me because this
story is told through Alicia's eyes and
it was very important to me that when
you get to the end of the film those
early scenes that were shot on 16 should
feel like Distant Memories and that was
really really important to me because
I just I I was really inspired by
looking through my parents photo albums
and just and and and also being a
photographer and I love looking at Old
images and I I just felt like how nice
would it be by the time because this
film covers a lot of ground it's 15
years it's two actors playing Alicia
it's a lot to ask of your audience so I
decided I was just going to lean into
that and I want you know like I said by
the end of the film when you're in that
when at the end of that third act all of
those memories of the beginning of the
movie should feel very distant like
faded photographs and that was the
intent
um I I everyone knows who watches any
interview I do I like talking about the
editing process because it's where it
all comes together yeah and even though
you had a limited shoot and I'm sure
limited takes I'm curious how the film
changed in the editing room in ways
perhaps you were not expecting
uh I had a two editors
um Peter and Larry and they were just
incredible and they um they put together
a beautiful uh editor's cut or what you
call it or you know a rough assembly so
as soon as I we got back from France I
sort of had the movie mapped out and
they did it exactly like the script and
um this was my first film so it seemed
heavy and long and weird and I was just
like oh my God this is but Sophia is the
best person to give you advice she's so
great at telling you calm down it's not
the end of the world you've got the
movie there that's what they all look
like even though my editors were telling
me no this story is solid it's there
um what happened is that I I decided at
one point I wanted to tell this
non-linear and I wanted the whole movie
to be a flashback and I think I was
telling you I went to dinner with Scoot
and he said how's the editing going I go
you know what I need I need to start
with Amelia and then she needs to be
looking through boxes and letters and we
need to start going back on her
childhood and we need to do all this and
and we played around with that for weeks
and this is the luxury I had because
when you have such a low budget movie in
your editing in somebody's living room
you know we did have a little bit more
flexibility
um but my editors let me do that and
they let me work that exercise and get
that out of my system Sophia kept
telling me
people gravitated to the story because
of your script you need to stick with
the script that's that's that's that's
what worked and I said no no no I think
it has to be non-linear and we tried it
and when you don't shoot something
non-linear and you don't write something
non-linear it's really hard to um
to try and put those puzzle pieces
together
um I spoke to uh an uh an editor that
had to do that once
um on a movie and she said well get
prepared for reshoots and focus groups
and all sorts of stuff because yeah and
and you know what I I went back to what
um the original assembly was and we just
fine-tuned that and it and I think it
really worked so but I was like I said I
was lucky that I was able I had the time
I could experiment with that but
um I think we're much better off you
know something I've spoken to a lot of
directors and they do sometimes some
real experimental editing and sometimes
it works but um but it's good to have
that freedom so at least you tried it
yeah and you know or to know that it
doesn't work yeah yeah you know so you
can move on from it 100 but even with
that the editing in this film
like I saw it for the first time in
theaters today I decided that I would
wait and I mean it's extraordinary how
it moves time periods so seamlessly like
that scene where Alicia is getting off
the bus I had a moment in in um the film
where I went like oh my God he's so
clever you know like just just
appreciating this is really moving along
like this is this is an extraordinary
it's extraordinarily well paced yeah
you don't understand how clever it was
because it constantly you're getting off
of a bus and then you're in a whole
nother City where she's walking and then
you're in a whole another city when or
100 another place of them talking to the
guy and they go Andrew did an insanely
good job at being able to to put these
locations in these things and be able to
utilize all these different
two-dimensional sort of walls or spaces
and stuff and then sew this thing
together like you had to have been there
to see how impressive it is on an
independent film the way that this thing
was sort of that he did and also the
producing team to be able to structure
that
um it really is for me like it was
phenomenal to be like wow you really
stitched that thing together like
seamlessly the stock footage is so cool
too because that blends in seamlessly
too it puts you there oh um I need to
wrap with you guys I was gonna I wanted
to talk we can talk at another Point
more about the film with more specifics
I'm just going to say uh congrats on
being in Sundance with this film
congrats on your first film being in
Sundance thanks guys which is crazy and
I thank you so much for coming in and
one more time because I want to a huge
thank you to Saratoga for being our
sponsor it's delicious it's kept us
hydrated yeah very refreshing we love
the blue bottles enjoy Sundance thank
you thank you thank you